imagine coming back to this
when you left it was a bustling vibrant
town
now it's the complete opposite
what would you be thinking
victor shows us his pride and joy a home
he built
here we had our bed tv and the wardrobe
were there
i replaced the windows indoors
everything was brand new under full
heating we are living a good life the
russian did not need to save us
absolutely not
they destroyed everything
energy yaroslav clears away bullets from
his apartment block
he doesn't want his kids to find them
when they eventually return
you can see how they pulled out the door
of my apartment
they pulled out the locks and broke in
apparently wanting to steal something
here was my kitchen
the water heater was on the floor here
was our air conditioner microwave fridge
stove
so they set fire to the mall
that's the beauty of the russian peace
this isn't reconstruction it's barely
even clearing but it is something
for the people we have spoken to it's
something that helps them get back some
control
gives them some hope that once again
this will be a bustling vibrant town
the government however is overwhelmed by
the sheer scale of what's required
official estimates suggest it'll take
seven years to rebuild when they
eventually begin
that's not to say the government isn't
doing anything it is it is
actually building bridges
and that's the priority for the
government is getting all the
infrastructure in place so people can
return but what they're returning to
well that's going to take a lot longer
to fix imran khan al jazeera rapine